okay okay good afternoon everybody my
name is Tom Pollard I'm a biology
professor and dean of the graduate
school and I'd like to welcome you to
the fourth of our company of scholars
lectures here at the graduate school for
this year this is a series of public
lectures meant to expose the scholarship
of our faculty here at Yale to a wider
audience and in that regard we've had
three very interesting lectures so far
on completely different topics the first
one by Jacob hacker had to do with
public policy and wealth distribution in
the United States the second by Beverly
gage had to do with J Edgar Hoover and
the foundation of the conservative
movement in the United States the third
one make a deal often had to do with the
impact of religion on parenting in the
United States so we have sort of a theme
of connection between our academic work
and the public for for our lecture
series this year and I selected my
friend paul tipton over here to give
this lecture because he wrote a very
thoughtful op-ed piece in the LA Times
that was distributed to other newspapers
by the LA Times on why the investment
made by the public around the world
through their taxes in this big physics
experiment was worthwhile so his topic
today is finding the Higgs boson what
our taxes taught us about mass so let me
tell you about Paul where he can take
the floor in a moment he has a doctor
lapre from the University of Rochester
and when I went off to UC Berkeley and
to the Fermilab in Illinois for
postdoctoral work returned to Rochester
rose through the faculty to full
professor in two thousand and two
thousand six we lured him here to Yale
he's now serving as the director of
graduate studies in the physics
department and on July first he will be
the next chair of physics here at Yale
so thank you very much for joining us
here today Paul
and thank you all for coming thank you
very much so it is my pleasure to bring
news of a momentous discovery in physics
and I'm sure you've heard about the
Higgs almost everyone you'd have to
really be hiding under a rock or
something to not hear anything about the
Higgs so what I'm going to try to do is
give a talk that complements what I hope
and think you probably already know I
want to start by thanking my my
colleagues both around the world on the
Atlas experiment of which I'm a member
but also my colleagues here at Yale to
be as calling Sarah vtech and keith
baker and also the physics librarian
kaylee and catherine james who is from
the by Nicki so let me start out with a
bit of a warning so in physics the big
three our space-time and mass and as
crummers alludes to any any very
important fundamental entity is going to
be hard to us to attach a well
established meaning to and so that's a
bit of a warning i'm going to try to do
that to define and understand mass at a
deep level and and a more succinct way
of saying that is that mass is a mess
and and now Wendy said this in the
context of inertial mass versus
gravitational mass and the lack of a
clear non circular definition but it
leads to the to the same idea so an
outline for today is I'm going to give a
rather lengthy introduction on the
history of mass and how the Higgs
relates to to that and then I'll talk
about the the Higgs search and how we
produce and detect the Higgs boson or
what we think is the Higgs boson what's
next at the LHC and then lessons beyond
sciences as Tom alluded to funding
ethics internationalism in taxes so so
it's going to be a big introduction and
a big conclusion with very little
sandwich of the Higgs search in between
okay so a brief history of mass so and
at the end I'm going to give lots of
opinion
and they're my opinions and I apologize
in advance if I offend anybody but I'm
going to give them anyways so and
speaking of offending i'm going to start
the history of mass skipping over the
ancients who gave us the theory of the
atom and start right away with with
Newton who gave us a theory of mass that
we could do something with a
quantitative theory with predictive
power Newton in principia the most
important of his works and arguably the
most important document in science today
on the first page of the first book of
Principia he tried to define mass and he
did so a by by you you know it's in
Latin of course so it's a quantity us
materi a which is a matter and when
would translate what comes next as
matter arising from its density and
volume conjointly so the problem with
Principia is that it's in Latin for the
first that's of one problem the second
problem is that it's basically math but
it's written in words so he didn't he
didn't basically have the algebraic
tools we have and so when you read it
you know it's like he's playing charades
you know I'm thinking of a oven of an
equation and he you know so in sentient
in paragraph armies so to translate this
into math which would I believe what he
was trying to say is that mass is
density times volume that's what most
people think he meant by that that
sentence which is a bit problematic
because density is mass over volume and
so we basically just go around in a
circle and our confusion about mass I
think can be traced back to this
beginnings where Newton stumbled over to
himself now Newton then went on to you
know with putting aside this circular
definition he used mass to get us F
equals MA and and M being the sort of
the charge of the gravitational force
and and you know operationally we now
can define mass right masses our ability
to resist acceleration because F equals
MA if you've got a big mass you can have
for a certain applied force your
acceleration will be less and and and
similarly in the gravitational equation
so you can
you can you can get somewhere with a
circular definition it turns out so so
we owe to Newton a bit of our confusion
now let me see echo okay so it turns out
that this story has a bit of a local
connection you know these newspapers
like to sell local connection so I'm
doing that now it turns out in 1713
there was a an agent for the colony of
Connecticut in London and his name was
Jeremiah dumber and he his job among
other things was to gather books for a
library for a new struggling college in
Connecticut and he went calling on the
head of the royal society at the time
was Isaac Newton any asked for some
donation of books in Isaac Newton in
1713 at a new a new version second
edition of bring capilla and he gave
jeremiah dumber a copy of that and
optics and a few other things and we
have here that copy a courtesy of the
author now it turns out this is probably
the second copy of Principia that made
its way across the pond the first went
to the colony of Pennsylvania and it was
given it was bought by James Logan so he
had to buy they had to buy theirs and we
got ours for free so that's good but uh
he read it and devoured he that he went
on to become the mayor of Philadelphia
but before he on the way of doing that
he taught himself calculus out of prank
epyon he he devoured any wrote letters
about it and there's scribblings in the
margins and everything it's quite
impressive and I invite you to come and
look at this copy and notice how clean
it is so either we're better to book so
we ignored this thing for many years I
don't know but we shouldn't ignore it
anymore so come in and appreciate the
the fine drawings and great work that it
is okay so after Newton the chemist
Lavoisier and others through studies of
chemical reactions came came to believe
that the the mass of the initial state
of any chemical reaction would would
equal the mass of the final state even
though the initial state might be carbon
and oxygen and the final state might
co2 and so that they in in their
language mass was neither created nor
destroyed which we now know is not
completely true but back then it was a
pretty good approximation the other
thing that they came upon was that their
view was that mass was inherent in an
essential product of an object or
material and that's because if you had a
mole of hydrogen it weighed a certain
number of grams and if it if you had a
mole of gas and it didn't way that it
wasn't hydrogen and so you know mass is
an essential feature of each element and
and it was viewed as such now to make
any more progress on the history of mass
we actually have to step back we're it's
1760 or 1780 and we have to start
learning about fields now the word field
was actually not used until about 1840
but the idea you know was in gestation
and we have a Faraday was was likely the
first one to use it in a scientific
publication so in in about 1810 it was
understood that one could map out in
pictures like like this one how a
positive charge would be influenced by
other charges and these maps were
curious they would tell you direction
and if you plotted the density of lines
you could actually get magnitude also so
they were very helpful inconvenient but
they really weren't viewed as real but
Faraday was a great experimentalist and
he played with gadgets and he came to
believe that in simple electric circuits
energy was taken out of that circuit to
set up a magnetic field and then when
you switched off the circuit the energy
would be dumped back into the the
circuit and so for a physicist if
something contains energy like he came
to believe the field did that was surely
real but he never really said it exactly
like that and it was it was a so he
worked mostly with magnetic charges but
the same thing could be stated about me
I'm sorry with with electrical charges
but the same thing could be said about
magnetic fields around mass I'm sorry
gravitational fields around masses so he
came to believe that fields contain
energy
and it was Maxwell later who who showed
through beautiful mathematics that light
was comprised of oscillating electric
and magnetic fields and since we all
believe light is real it's not hard then
to believe that the underlying fields
that that are contained within it are
also real now one might ask our water
waves really real maybe it's just the
water that's real meaning maybe it's the
vehicle or the medium for a wave that's
the real thing but Einstein came to to
take the work of Davisson and Germer and
others who I'm sorry Michelson and
Morley and others who who gave us
evidence that that there is no medium
for light that light is traveling it's
self-propagating and it travels in the
vacuum and and so if if these fields are
independent of any medium then clearly
they're there in and of themselves real
and they carry energy in fact later on
in general relativity Einstein told us
that that matter can deform space and
time and in fact all forms of energy can
deform space and time so fields alter
the space therein and so clearly they're
they're quite real so now we can go back
to talk about mass and we're up to about
1910 and we want to talk about the new
idea in 1918 or so that debroy had that
that if if light is both wave and
particle the particulate nature of light
was described in a paper by Einstein in
1905 if light is both wave and particle
maybe maybe the electron in all forms of
matter are and by 1925 that had been
experimentally demonstrated so now
quantum mechanics is basically telling
us that light is made out of a quantized
oscillating field and in fact all matter
is also quantized oscillating fields but
their matter fields instead of electric
and magnetic fields so so now fields
have got to be pretty real because they
make up make up pretty much everything
around us in in 1935 you kawa came up
with the idea of how we could actually
do calculations with this
idea how we might be able to see how one
particle influences another and that is
by exchanging a third particle which
incidentally is also made out of fields
quantized fields so so it was fine men
who told us that electric and magnetic
forces on the subatomic level the four
primary particles are mediated by by the
exchange of photons and that was the
first of what we would call a quantum
field theory so just on a macroscopic
level just just as these people if they
were standing on ice could exert a
repulsive force by exchanging a heavy
ball by each pushing against the ball
and accepting momentum from the ball so
on the subatomic level particles can
exchange a third particle and influence
each other so that's that's the basic
idea then it was it was fine men who
made these calculations relatively easy
anybody who's taken graduate quantum
field theory knows they're not easy easy
but they're relatively easy and there's
just one idea than to get us to where we
where we are today and that is that in
the mid-nineteen so Fineman did his work
in about nineteen forty eight and by 55
people were struggling to try to explain
the other forces in terms of field
theories to mimic what Fineman did for
electricity and magnetism but it was
young and Mills who made a uh who made a
big discovery and that is that the field
of mathematics called group Theory has a
lot of parallels to the quantum algebra
of quantum field theory and and it to
make further progress they basically
said if you find the right group that
will the rules about how this group
behaves will inform the physics and in
fact if you find the right groups you'll
be instantly able to to write down the
rules of the physics and so by nineteen
sixty five or so people were able to
write down a group that encompassed the
the known forces except for gravity and
so here's a one slide summary of what we
call the standard model of physics for
those of you who know group theory
that's the group for those of you don't
ignore that
that thing but basically that gives us
in detail how how gluons are exchanged
in the in the the nucleus to hold it
together and why the electron that
orbits around them is is not sucked into
the nucleus because it doesn't
participate in the strong force so here
are the building blocks of the standard
model the quarks the six purple quartz
quarks here the green leptons the
electron and it's sort of heavier
companion or sibling the muon which
decays into the electron and then the
tau which is even heavier and can decay
into the electron of the muon or in fact
it's got some other options that it can
do and here are the mediators the photon
mediates the the electromagnetic force
the gluon mediates the strong force
within the nucleus and then the very
heavy W and Z's mediate the weak force
so that's sort of a map you know it
looks very kludgy and qualitative but it
works in detail and it's made thousands
of predictions to very accurate
predictions precise predictions that
appear to be accurate also so but there
is one last problem and this problem is
that this theory of matter of how matter
organizes itself wants everything to be
massless and that's that's actually a
problem and I think it deserves a very
big frowny face so the problem is and
this can't be swept under the rug we
can't just say well you know the masses
are all 0 and we're going to paste a
mass in there because there's certain
things that have been similar certain
symmetries that have to be obeyed that
that if you give the particles mass you
know it's very bad so everything wants
to be like the photon made of fields but
but fundamentally having no rest mass
but but the idea the fix is to propose a
ubiquitous field thats everywhere since
massive objects have mass wherever they
are and mass will be generated through
an interaction between these these
massless fields that are the electron or
the cork and and this ubiquitous field
and dynamically mass will be generated
through that interaction and if you put
that into the theory it works quite well
and it really it you know it doesn't
look like a kludgy sort of a
even though it was at some level so and
the nice thing about this theory is that
it has predictive power it predicts so
so that the Higgs worse like this so the
Higgs gives mass to objects whether
they're moving or not but the best way
to understand it the best bad example of
the of of how the Higgs works is that if
the electron moves through the Higgs
field sort of like a particle through
water and therefore we interpret it as
being very light but the top cork is
very heavy and it moves through the
Higgs field as if it was molasses and it
turns out that this molasses can self
interact and give us the molasses ball
which is the Higgs boson and it can only
do that when it's got enough energy to
do that it doesn't spontaneously make
Higgs bosons all over the place it's
gotta conserve energy but but but it
does have this predictive a prediction
that the Higgs boson should exist and
because the masses of the particles are
all wrapped up in the in this theory we
even know roughly where to look for the
Higgs boson so since I know you're a
well-educated have been reading the
newspaper I want to clear up some
misconceptions you might have it was
stated in the news last July that the
Higgs field is responsible for all the
mass in the universe that is certainly
not true so let's talk about our mass
we're made out of neutrons and protons
almost exclusively and and and that mass
the mass of the proton is is really not
from the Higgs interaction so the mass
of the quarks within within the the
proton are gotten through the
interaction with the Higgs but the this
the proton looks something like this it
looks like three quarks that each have
the charge of the strong force so that
and it's a very very powerful charge so
that around it is this intense field a
gluon field but that that that those
gluons are trapped in being exchanged in
between these quarks and trap the quarks
within the proton but this huge amount
of energy via special relativity is
interpreted as mass so here equals MC
squared is really the e of the these
of these fields being interpreted as an
M and that's really what the proton is
only about ten percent comes from the
quarks and most of that is the strange
cork that you know isn't really one of
these three okay so so that's that's
that so now you might ask the astute
listener might might ask how is it that
these massless fields can give a massive
object well the answer is Einstein said
it could and so therefore it's got to be
true but let me give a better example
suppose we had a mirrored box and a
laser pointer which we have and we take
two mirrored boxes so on the inside of
these boxes are all mirrors and there's
a there's a little hole you can't really
see that but there's a little hole right
there so we shine our laser pointer into
one of them and lo and behold it will
get heavier now it turns out if you if
you try this with my laser pointer it
turns out it would take between a
hundred five hundred years to pump
enough energy into that box to make it
sort of a microgram heavier so you don't
want to try this at home anyone but it
turns out that people Jack Harris who's
a very clever experimentalist here is
thinking about ways to do something
similar to this and that that is very
exciting so to summarize so far in 1810
the word field hadn't really been used
in physics but but we did sort of map
out field lines and they were a
mathematical convenience but not thought
to be real and by 2013 and of course
mass was certainly thought to be real in
1810 but now we think that everything
that's real is comprised of field so
both matter and light and that mass is
dynamically generated so your masses is
generated from instant to instant as
quarks are swarming around the proton
being emitted and absorbed I'm sorry as
gluons are being emitted and absorbed by
the quarks of in real time and all the
mysteries of this are sort of swept up
into this ubiquitous field thats
everywhere and and this is sort of the
second time we've had one of these
fields that lives everywhere and many
physicists don't really like it but but
where we're stuck with it
and if this theory is correct we r
correct is it somewhat in quotes because
it might be you know a low-energy
approximation or something like that it
might be replaced someday but but if it
holds together at all then we ought to
find the Higgs boson so how do we go
about finding the Higgs well I've
implied that the Higgs is very unstable
it lives about 10 to minus 25 seconds
which is pretty darn quick so you want
it you can't just go out and dig up half
of western Pennsylvania you know put it
through some machine and sort it and
look for Higgs because they're not going
to be there but you can make them if
you've got enough energy so what we do
is is take counter-rotating beams of
protons with very very high kinetic
energy and we collide them head-on and
that energy then is available to make
mass so again we're using e to MC
squared taking our energy of kinetic
energy and putting it into mass and that
mass can do many things but one of the
things that can I'm sorry that energy
can do many things but one of the things
that can do is make a Higgs boson the
accelerators the LHC and here's a sort
of a schematic representation so this is
a the Geneva Airport and this is Geneva
and you can't really see the ring as you
as you fly in because it's about 200
meters underground but but this is what
it would look like if you had x-ray
vision so there are four big experiments
and Yale is involved in two of them the
Atlas experiment on the upper right and
the Elysee experiment that Helen canes
and John John Harris are involved in so
and and and the the collision energy at
maximum will be seventeen TV or 7,000
I'm sorry 70 EV / beam 14 t EV for the
total and that's an a proton weighs
about a GeV so this is like 14,000 times
the energy of a proton so let's just
walk through some of the details this is
an amazing machine one of the largest
machines in the world it's in a 16-mile
tunnel that's its underground it'smay
it's basically a 16-mile ring of
for conducting magnets that are all at
about two degrees Kelvin takes about
ninety six tons of liquid helium to keep
them that way here's a picture of one of
the last mag the last magnet being
lowered down in April of 2007 through
one of the the access shafts and here's
a picture of the final assembled magnets
and you can see the gentle curvature and
the person riding in the tunnel just
because he can now the main thing about
the LHC is that it's an amazing machine
and we want to use it again and again
and again so we want to make sure that
when we put beam in it we've got an exit
strategy for how to get the beam out
safely so we it in it that's a big task
because when when particles are going
very close to the speed of light you can
really they can hold a lot of energy and
so if we we have the LHC filled to
capacity at design energy it has the
energy the kinetic the equivalent
kinetic energy of a 747 during takeoff
but that's not the only energy that the
LHC is storing there's a huge amount of
energy in the magnetic field that's used
to bend the the protons trajectory into
this 16 mile circle and that energy is
747 at cruise cruising speed so one has
to be very careful and we've we've tried
very hard to take care with this machine
so our first data from the LHC we have
collision data from September 2008 when
we first started turning on the thing
and collision data we recall a collision
data because we're trying to collide
protons with protons but in fact this
was magnet magnet collisions because our
protection didn't really work so we we
ended up having an open between two
magnets and that caused this
catastrophic magnetic force that
repelled the magnets and bumped them
there was literally a train wreck where
magnets are bumping into magnets down
the chain and we ruined about 40 magnets
but it turns out we had about 50 spares
and so after readjusting our protection
circuitry in about ten months we are
underway and now I think it is safe to
describe the LHC as the biggest Swiss
watch in the world
it's an amazing machine that functions
amazingly well and we owe a huge debt of
gratitude to those who who did research
and development and prototyping and then
built it and operate it because it's an
amazing scientific instrument so the LHC
can provide data that that will allow us
to see the remnants of the Higgs once it
decays but we have to first understand
what it should decay into turns out that
about eighty percent of the time it
decays into things that that blend in
with the background with the other
things that these high-energy protons
can make when they collide and so we
almost by necessity have to ignore most
of what the Higgs decays into but the
the largest thing that we're currently
actually looking for is looking forward
to decay into the heavy companion to the
electron called the towel and Emma ideal
and Sarah demers are currently looking
for the Higgs decaying into tau pairs
here at Yale and with colleagues at CERN
keith baker is working on trying to see
it in two pairs of the heavy boson the z
and a slightly lighter version of busy
that it's you know it's it's what we
call off shell because it doesn't quite
have enough energy to have its true mass
these are the Z Z star mode is really a
gold plated mode because we'll be able
to reconstruct from these four well
measured particles will be able to tell
the initial mass of the Higgs and the
last mode only happens you know two
times out of a thousand but it's to two
very simple particles two photons and
our energy resolution on photons is very
good and two-photon events are not that
common so we can in a very narrow range
hopefully see an excess of if the Higgs
is there so that's our search strategy
here's a picture of the Atlas detector
that Yale is involved in it you know
when I started in high energy physics
you could put an experiment in a room a
normal sized room and then then
experiments were sort of the size of a
small house and then they got to be a
size of a big house
us and this is more like a city block
you know these are people here and
they're not miniature people it's you
know a couple hundred million electronic
channels it takes many scientists to
prepare those there to prototype them
and and and bring them into existence
and then operate it we have about a
thousand graduate students and lots of
other things on it let's try to briefly
explain how it works we try to learn
different things about the particles in
different regions so in the innermost
region we try to let the particles pass
through without interact without
absorbing them but but sensing them
through very thin wafers of silicon for
example and so we track the particle
there in these regions where we've got
calorimeters we try to absorb the total
energy of the particles and by where
whether early or late we can learn about
the particles identity and we can learn
about whether it's charged or not by
whether it left a track and the tracker
and if particles made it all the way
through left to track and hits in the
outermost layer we know that that was
very likely a meal on and in neutrino
its Kate escapes our detector leaving no
trace but we know that momentum had to
be conserved so by everything going to
one side we know the neutrino had to go
in the other direction so that's
basically how we do our business CMS is
sort of our rival and companion
experiment it's much it's much smaller
but it's more dense so there there you
can see I don't really have time to to
talk about this i know my colleagues at
CMS will probably be miffed at me but
nonetheless we have to move on so CMS is
smaller but it's more dense it weighs
about thirty percent more than the
eiffel tower so it you know this is the
compact detector atlas it turns out
weighs about eighty percent of the
eiffel tower and had we known that this
slide was going to be shown all over the
world i'm sure we could have brought
twenty percent more mass to the problem
and exceeded the eiffel tower but that
might have been a waste so so the the
search itself starts with producing the
LHC so the unfortunate news is that we
only produce a Higgs one every billion
in Iraq
shins so we're going to be searching for
the the needle among many haystacks and
in it will be hard to find in the the
data collected in 2011 we produced about
70,000 Higgs and you'll know that we can
only play around with a few hundred of
those and really extract them and
unfortunately again we don't get 10 to
the 15 individual interactions we get
about ten at a time that overlay and
that that's problematic in 2012 we did a
little better we got we got many more
hips but of course we had 20
interactions / beam crossing as a cost
of the higher intensity intensity beam
and as I said only about two percent
point two percent of all the Higgs
produced end up being significantly
above background in some mode that we
can definitively identify so here's a
here's an example this is a picture of
just the inner part of the Atlas
detector so this is about 20 centimeters
across maybe 25 centimeters across in
each of these these planes here is sort
of like the the focal plane of your of
your digital camera and but it's not
really taking an optical image it's more
just looking for a particle to pass
through one of the pixels and give a
current pulse and it has to do that
every 30 nanoseconds or so so it's a
very fast camera and this is what we
hope to c z decaying 22 I'm sorry H
decaying to 2 z's it then give you
something like four muons so here are
the four muons and then here are some
other tracks that it gave but it's
relatively clean but unfortunately what
we see is this where there are ten other
additional events over top at an easy
curly circles come about because it all
this is is in a cylinder so what excuse
me what we're looking at is proton into
the board proton out of the board the
interaction would be there we're started
looking at a cross-section of what
happens as things fly out from from that
interaction region now we can turn the
turn the thing sideways and look sort of
along the beam line and we can see that
these vertices separate and that really
helps us clear up this problem be can we
we can I
if I which tracks go with which vertices
and here we've clearly identified a
vertex that as two very energetic tracks
that that that come from Z boson decay
so with these sorts of techniques we can
begin to extract Higgs from from the
background so we use control samples to
a great extent so this thesis comes from
Yale's first PhD on the Atlas experiment
Jennifer sh shoe in it shows the
reconstruction of the Z boson when it
decays into two electrons and the line
the solid line is our computer
prediction given what we know about the
physics and fineman's rules versus what
we observe in the data and the points
and you can see the agreement is quite
good and that gives us a confidence that
we understand the tracking chamber that
was used for this and the calorimeter
and and our rate of detecting electrons
and so on now with with much more oops I
miss something something got deleted all
right well we collected millions more
bigger samples than this and with it
we've been able to to access just this
tail of the distribution and look at
this this distribution over five orders
of magnitude and see that it also agrees
and if our resolution if our detector
resolution wasn't correct that would not
be correct and and so on so we can
really get to the point where we're
confident that if the Higgs existed we
would see it so then we go and look at
the data and these data are from the
Atlas experiment in the the mode where
we're looking just for for two photons
in the event and of course there'll be
lots of other things and through the
clever use of background samples we can
get the the shape of what the background
should be in the absence of signals and
then we can subtract that off and that's
what we have here we've got the data
points are these data minus this dashed
curve and you can see that that it fits
nicely to an experimental to the
prediction of what we'd expect
our resolution to be if if this object
was 125 GeV Higgs we we see an excess of
about 440 events in this sample we
expected about a three standard
deviation effect and we observed
actually a six standard deviation effect
so we have served about eighty percent
more Higgs than we expected but we have
uncertainties in our our efficiencies
and and many things that that make us
less sure that that eighty percent is is
is not a statistical fluctuation so
it'll take more data for us to really
understand that in fact with new data
these numbers are coming down to closer
to what the standard model is is
predicting so I in in in a second
independent set of data we're looking
for the Higgs decaying into four leptons
in the Z Z star a mode that kita
professor Keith Baker's looking at so
this this mode is very nice it's almost
self-calibrating this this peak down
here at the bottom is the Z decaying 24
leptons which it does rarely but it does
do quite frequently and much often more
often than the Higgs and we can loosen
up our selection criteria to get more of
them because it's relatively clean and
again we can compare it to what we
expect and the rate is almost exactly as
we expected it to be and the resolution
is is quite similar so that lets us know
that if the Higgs is there we ought to
see it and in fact if you focus here at
125 GeV we've got an excess in plus or
minus five GeV of 125 we see 18 when we
expect only 8.3 and that's about a four
standard deviation effect now our
companion experiment the CMS sees a
lovely two photon data and also 44
lepton data that's consistent with ours
and consistent with a statistical excess
at the same mass and so in terms of
statistics this is not in doubt we found
something new and that's very exciting
so the question is are we finished the
first thing we certainly have discovered
a new object and it the question is is
is the standard model complete is this
the
the particle that that would complete it
and that would charge us to go and
measure properties that so if the if it
is the standard model then Higgs then we
know what it will decay into and we we
know certain angular distributions of
what those decay products should be and
we can test those against what we expect
from the standard model so far the in
the indications are that this is
consistent with the Standard Model Higgs
however we can we can further and in
great detail study what it decays into
at what rates and and how it does that
how its produced and how it decays and
through what are called quantum
fluctuations within the Higgs at before
it decays we can probe much higher
energies than we can directly so this
this is sort of the birth of a new field
of physics and in addition to that the
the standard model is successful as it
is has some rather serious flaws flaws
of omission because it doesn't talk
about dark matter or dark energy which
dominate the universe we live in and it
also has some technical problems it it
predicts it has some almost nonsensical
calculations within it that that lead us
to believe that those calculations must
be wrong that some new phenomena must
come in and change how we do those
calculations and they must then those
new phenomena would be new particles or
new forces and we believe they're within
our experimental reach hopefully within
the reach of the LHC as we go up in
energy but of course that's not
guaranteed so let me first summarize the
scientific lessons from from what we
learned we have a relatively complete
picture of mass you know we're good at
it it housed but not so good at why so I
put complete in quotes it's a beautiful
picture of mass it's very elegantly
described by quantum mechanics it in
1810 mass was real and fields were math
and now everything is comprised of
quantized field fields and mass is not
inherent it's dynamically generated in
fact it's calculable with if you input
the proton mass to qcd calculations you
can get the spectrum of sort of
states of excited protons baryon so
they're called in detail and it's it's
quite exciting the last piece of the
puzzle the higgs boson is really a huge
experimental turret of force and
proceeding it in an incredible
intellectual turret of force the
standard model does contain flaws and in
addition to using this new new thing the
Higgs as a scientific laboratory we're
hoping to find something new beyond the
Higgs so now now we switch from what we
know to what I think so in ode to
internationalism so this big science
project was done internationally and in
doing so we we avoided everybody having
one of these in their own backyard which
certainly avoided duplication of cost to
cost about ten billion dollars so you
don't want to do this in every backyard
we spread the financial burden as
broadly as possible almost every
taxpayer on the planet had skin in the
game taxpayers in China India you know
everywhere the u.s. South America almost
all taxpayers can contributed it it
helped us develop patterns of
international cooperation in a
relatively non-controversial site right
so we're not trying to do a treaty to a
control global warming or something even
more complicated like maybe trying to
site the Olympics or something we're
just trying to to do a science project
together but yet of course to do it we
all have to have visas from our
countries and so on and we have to
cooperate and and and and so on so it's
a it's a good it's a good way for us to
intertwine the fates of many countries
and I think we did that because we all
wanted this to succeed and what's really
nice is that everybody on the results
right this isn't an American result it's
not a Western result or you know some
hundred countries represented in this
discovery so everybody owns it as it
should be so an ode to taxes taxes are
what we pay for civilized society Oliver
Wendell Holmes i think curiosity driven
research is an excellent use of our our
common resources which is to say taxes
it allows us to spread out these things
that are that are potentially not very
practical so high-energy physics has
given an CERN have given the world many
great things from the World Wide Web to
you know whatever but but if one wanted
spin-offs you wouldn't start by saying
let's find the Higgs boson I'm sure
we'll get a lot of spin-offs that way
you'd spend your money differently so
this is really motivated by curiosity by
the human condition which is curious
about our surroundings and the beautiful
world we live in which seems appropriate
to study the alternatives to doing this
curiosity based research with taxes is
to not do the science at all which is
certainly a possibility or to try to
find corporate sponsors you know if
that's even possible but of course there
you're mixing a for-profit and
not-for-profit entities and and that
could get very complicated it might be
how this hat takes place in the future
but I think that's a less I think that
could be very messy so then we can ask
it has this been worth it so being a
taxpayer probably cost you a couple
dollars over the last two two decades of
your tax money to find the Higgs and I
hope you found it worthwhile so it's
it's cheap compared to the cost of a
movie ticket think about it that way but
and it was spread over two decades so
that's good now Robert Fineman as he was
trying to justify Fermilab which was
built in the 70s said that Fermilab or
high energy physics has nothing directly
to do with defending our country except
to make it worth defending he was he was
trying to argue that we should build
this Accelerator lab instead of another
defense lab and I I think that's true
this money is worth it because it
because it helps us do what humans like
to do we are innately curious and if
we're busy being curious we're not
killing each other there's a lot of good
things that come out of us being curious
so you could ask about opportunity cost
so given other global needs can the
planet afford this quote-unquote
frivolous activity and I this question
was raised to me because after the op-ed
piece that Tom mentioned I got some
blowback basically many people thought
this op-ed was very self-serving which
of course it was but others said you
know what would prefer what I got 11
email in particular that said I wonder
what Professor Tipton would say to the
25,000 parents who lost children due to
preventable diseases today and that of
course is a very serious question that
we have to address and so after some
thought and a glass of wine I answered
the gentleman and we had a give and take
that was actually quite quite used
useful so that one one way of addressing
this is that it's uh it's it's not
obvious that poverty and preventable
disease are financially limited anyway
it's probably war in corruption that
they keep that from happening and you
know many will argue with them but
Jeffrey Sachs says that of order point
seven percent of the GDP of the
developed world could and using it
wisely could could end poverty so people
can argue with that but that's a
ballpark figure now that should be
compared to four point seven percent of
the the GDP we spend on defense and
point O one percent that we spend on
particle physics research so if sex is
right you know you could cancel all of
high-energy physics and you wouldn't do
much to help us out of the mess we're in
ok so my second to last slide I just
want to spend a minute doing a funny
sort of mental exercise so in my field
we do it what are called pseudo
experiments we we simulate samples of
data with computer-generated models and
we do this millions of times to try to
you know understand the the breadth of
possibilities and the statistical nature
of what we're about to see so these are
called pseudo experiments and I want to
imagine running human history a million
times as we run our experiments a
million times on the computer so this is
something we can actually do but it's so
it's a Gedanken experiment it's
something that that Einstein would would
would have us think about doing an
experiment you can't really do but you'd
like to do so we've been around for
about 200,000 years so let's try to reap
I this 200,000 years many many times say
a million times how often in in those
million times would we get to develop
symbolic culture in a written language
so symbolic culture has probably been
around for a hundred thousand years
through may be ornamental jewelry and
and things like that that probably
expressed something symbolically to
written language that it's probably more
like twenty thousand years i think i
hope i have that right so it's
relatively late in in our 200,000 years
history it might be that we never would
have gotten to it in two hundred
thousand years would we reach the bronze
age would we be able to manipulate money
would we get to indoor plumbing this is
on many people's minds i think you know
this is this is a huge human advancement
would we get to the scientific method i
note that we've only had the scientific
method for 500 of those 200,000 years so
you could well imagine that that you
humans could have been around for
200,000 years and not got to the
scientific method which of course would
mean we wouldn't get to special
relativity and nuclear power which is
bad but of course we wouldn't have been
able to blow ourselves up which is good
so it's amazing that we've gotten this
far and we haven't blown ourselves up
and then we went further developed
quantum mechanics quantum field theory
predicted the Higgs and then we're able
to have the affluence in permission of
society to to go out and spend the
billions to bring it about now koat this
is very physics centric you know the
mechanical engineer would say that you
know how often would we get to the
development of the wheel and how often
would that lead to the Segway and so on
but but in physics this is this is how
we look at the world and you know uh you
know i'm i'm really not sort of a mr.
rogers type are much more like the two
grumpy guys in the back of the room and
the muppets you know but but I I do have
to say that that you know up with people
right we got it right this time it's
very self-serving for me to say that
what I was involved in is sort of the
pinnacle of human society and believe me
I know that there's a lot of sausage
made in high energy physics there's a
lot of politics and backbiting and you
know it's not all wonderful and you know
we certainly express all of the emotions
and actions and abilities of
human behavior but we we at least helped
us to a common goal of the scientific
discovery so to summarize I don't know
why so beyond the sign so here's to
summarize my opinions the Higgs
discovery was quite global so I don't
know why I thought that a scoreboard was
an appropriate way to finish this talk
but this is a scoreboard that you might
appreciate so the Higgs discovery was
quite global and that's score one for
international cooperation in 04 sort of
material nationalistic rancor and so on
it was supported by practically every
taxpayer on on the planet so score one
for the glories and virtues of Taxation
and 0 for Hyper end of individualism it
was brought about without corporate
sponsorship and so it's the Higgs boson
it's not the microsoft boson which you
know it could have gone that way so I
think that's a good thing human
curiosity trumped all that we were able
to get beyond ourselves and do something
that at its root is is based in
curiosity and not you know the profit
motive or other human activities that
are perfectly fine so strike one for
human curiosity and 0 for motives lower
on maslow's hierarchy so what about
opportunity cost well as 114 big science
and 0 for everything else for example
curing eliminating curable diseases but
I think that's a false dichotomy I don't
think that we have to make that choice
and we have enough resources to do to do
it all or to do at least those do thank
you very much for your attention
okay I now probably delighted to answer
your questions so please yes Machado in
one of your slides you said the
non-controversial isn't that a bit
dangerous if there is no more
controversy in science what what today
in in what context without so so
Michelle is asking me I'm in one in in
one on one slide I said something was
non-controversial so what what in what I
don't remember writing that down I deny
it I think you said this in relation to
the unity of the team because our
teamwork and it was noncontroversial oh
oh no what I meant was that what we were
doing was not controversial like trying
to put a treaty on global warming we
were all deciding you know we had all
signed up to try to find to do do
discovery physics at the LHC so in that
sense it was not controversial we
weren't at odds over our basic premise
for why we were in the room at most days
so in that sense it was not
controversial it was absolutely i mean
many of us I have to go on record now is
saying that I never thought this thing
was there the Higgs just felt too weird
you know we're going back to the ether
right this ubiquitous field is
everywhere I don't like this idea at all
but it's there and it actually is quite
elegant even though I don't like it and
so in its and it's probably true so yes
I think there were many dissenters in
the room but all of us wanted to know
the answer you know I think they're
certainly we're biases and and hopefully
we put those aside yes
so it it that the Higgs field gives all
elementary particles the quarks and the
leptons the W and the mediators the w's
in disease but but not the photon it
leaves the photon alone it gives those
absolutely fundamental entities their
mass so so just like in Argo i can give
you our best bad analogy you know the
best bad analogy is that is that we move
the as particles move through this
ubiquitous ether it's like a drag force
and and that the drag is proportional to
how strongly the the particle couples to
the Higgs field and so heavy objects
couple strongly and light objects don't
couple strongly and move through it
quite well now the flaw in that argument
and flaw in that analogy is that the
Higgs gives mass to objects whether
they're moving or not this is not about
resisting acceleration or resisting
motion so it is a flawed argument but
it's the best flawed argument we have I
can pick yes objects are moving the more
mass they have so the question is is is
this related to Einstein's ideas about
time dilation is is moving through the
Higgs field like that and the answer is
no for for the exact reason I just said
that objects have masked whether they're
moving through the feet Higgs field or
not Mestas objects like photons don't
even know the Higgs field is there it's
like it's like a neutral object not
knowing that there's an electric field
there right that's
sweetie why they're going to be a lot
more massive ought to us but of course
not to themselves like okay so there is
some zur observer now who thinks you're
moving very close to the speed of light
but you obviously don't think you're
heavier than you normally are yes so the
question is I mentioned space-time in
mass is the big three and you said how
about energy and that the truth is the
best definition of mass is that it's
it's a very common form of energy and
it's the most common form of really
really dense energy right so so it
appears to be anomalous but it's
actually and it perhaps is because it's
also the charge of gravity so it
probably is special but yes it is just a
form of energy and general relativity is
a theory of gravity but it's also a
theory of how energy couples to a matter
into it to its itself oh so and so the
question is about dark energy and how
that works and I can answer that very
easily we don't know how dark energy
works yeah that would be an excellent
PhD thesis for all of you following
along at home write that down that's a
great big topic so there's a lot about
dark energy that we have just begun to
to touch yes Peter big project might
involve you know five or ten students we
have a hard time finding
and even when there's two students doing
the same thing with sometimes worry you
know I said etc now at us alone had a
thousand a thousand PG students yeah so
the question is about the sociology of
large experiments how is it that we can
have a thousand graduate students and
know what each is doing and and be able
to advance their careers by
understanding what they do individually
and and you said that in astronomy we
really don't like to have a student do
two students do the same topic and
that's true in high energy also there
are hundreds and hundreds of interesting
things to do with in atlas rarely do we
have students doing exactly the same
thing so i showed you sort of what are
called the cut and count there's other
people are doing this with neural Nets
there there are people looking in
various decay modes or people who who
wrote a thesis on the first part of the
data and now postdocs so you can divide
it up many ways and have individual
ownership of work and ideas and and so
on what we have to do is rely on on
letters of recommendation because you
can't just point to a publication list
because as Tom pointed out to me I have
850 publications and that's an
embarrassing number you know I ah yes
the papers / author I'm pretty low so
when ad list publishes a paper we have
of order is it about two thousand names
signing it so you know so I on many of
those papers i only own like 12
thousandth of the paper so it all works
out yes
logical question so they're all these
different experiments going postdocs
working and products working two
different experiments at some point the
decision is we need to make the
announcement I remember I was actually
so that the question is how do we how do
we know to what what sets our schedule
basically Wow why is it we made an
announcement at certain time so there
are certain big so it high-energy
physics is highly ritualized we have
these conventions and conferences every
year and you go there and pay homage and
stuff so our schedule revolves around
these conferences so then the
accelerator sets it's scheduled around
these conferences and so then the
accelerator when when they give us the
data is set so that we have a big slug
of data right before these conferences
and can analyze it and and and so it's
sort of self-fulfilling prophecy that we
get big results before big conferences
because that's how we designed it and
why these you know why these conferences
happen to be the lucky ones you know it
gets kind of crazy but that's that's
basically what's going on and and we try
to give data and you know lots of big
conferences come and go without major
discoveries it's when you get that
biggest log of data before an important
conference and everybody's ready
Catherine if you have a Newtonian world
view of a sort of you that measurements
can be observed and you know reliable
laws by which the world cami Anderson
and then you have an Einstein Ian
worldview of perspective what would the
Higgs boson Ian worldview be the
philosophical implications that's very
interesting that's variant so the
question was Newton gave us a certain
way of looking at the world sort of the
the classical the world is a is a
well-made clock and then Newton and
Einstein sort of brought in relativity
and that you know it depends on your
perspective so what what philosophy
would be informed by the Higgs that is
really an excellent question let me know
when you get an answer I think I i I'm
sure there I'm sure it's just a short
sightedness on my part not being able to
come up with something but now and maybe
in 50 years it will be obvious and
people laugh at me for not knowing the
answer but I I don't you know it's sort
of the the quantum view I guess but do
any of the other physicists in the room
have an answer yeah the quantum world
that things are understood statistically
but it in the high students statistic
limits you get back what Einstein and
and and Newton would have predicted and
so it's a radical departure you know we
can't tell where each electron is going
in fact the electron doesn't even have a
position until you measure it so that's
sort of crazy making in a different way
that Einstein was crazy making but in
the end of the day you make measurements
and compare it to theory in it and it's
all good these are great questions lets
up two more Oh Paul you can yes okay so
the question is why why don't we solve
this issue of big authors the way the
French mathematician big groups of
authors of a French mathematicians did
and i would say that getting all those
friends mathematicians to make a
decision and is anomalous i mean for us
to be able to get it in a room and make
a decision i've actually been in the
room where we tried to do things
differently let's just have first author
be the graduate student but then which
great you know if there are two graduate
students they contributed you know and
and it's so it just gets messy and and
again it's sort of our this is our our
best worst idea right it's our best bad
idea and and and the astronomers do it
differently and perhaps better they they
do
get together to do these big projects
but then when they publish they publish
in small groups in in in high-energy we
do our work in small groups but then
everybody is on it that's why I have 850
publications in truth I'm only doing two
or three serious publications a year
with with my group and and those really
count and those are the ones i highlight
and and so on but yeah we're stuck with
the system unfortunately yes blue
turtleneck oh I'm sorry no no we got to
go with the yes so the question was was
I surprised or did did I ever was i
surprised about the level of attention
and did I feel like it was perhaps bad
that's that's also a very good question
I was surprised I mean I I was involved
in a fairly big discovery in in 1994 at
Fermilab and that was a big deal and I
was really at the center of it and you
know it was it was huge there were lots
of articles and I thought it was great
this is so much bigger and I had no idea
it would be so much bigger and so I was
surprised and do I think it's bad I mean
you paid for it you know don't read the
newspapers if you don't want you know
don't go to the movie right you you you
paid to go to this movie you paid to
make this movie but you don't have to go
to it so you can ignore it I thought it
was good i thought you know there were
aspects that were bad like yeah i'm
always harking back to the god particle
which you know is flamboyant and that
was that was invented to sell books and
it did but it hasn't served us well and
so that that's probably the only aspect
of this that has been negative now I
think it's good for science I think it's
good
we're sharing one mic here so let me on
behalf of the entire group thank Paul
for this lovely talk that really got us
up to speed up and then let me invite
for you to a reception which will take
place next door in the common room but
on your way out I suggest you come by
and take a look at this book up here I
thought I would never see a copy of this
book in my life and it's sitting right
here in fact I'm touching to right now
many it turns out we got copies of the
first edition we got unbelievable things
anyway this is one of the great